the Joe Rogan experience things like
that so now in your book did you go over
near-death experiences do you have a
background what do you think is going on
like when people like the ones that have
fascinated me are people in the hospital
bed that see their body from above and
you're dealing with a bunch of chemicals
that are released in the body right
there's morphine and all sorts of
different things you know
you know psychedelic chemicals and all
these different things that are
happening while your brain is is
basically on the edge of death right so
it's important to remember that their
their near-death experiences you're not
actually dead so there's there's a
luminal transitional stage there where
you're sliding into some other state of
consciousness an altered state of
consciousness and we know that if you
inject or you take hallucinogens you
know those are molecular molecules that
operate on a lock-and-key mechanism with
the synapses in your brain in your
neurons so if they these external drugs
work in this molecular lock-and-key
mechanism there must be natural
chemicals similar molecular lis to that
in the brain already just in smaller
doses so one theory about near-death
experiences is that is that this is a
way of transitioning from living to dead
without feeling anxious and falling
apart and upset and depressed or
whatever it's kind of a smooth feel good
you know better than a morphine drip
kind of way of making the transition and
but we know for example that this
scientist named dr. James whinnery
worked for the United States Air Force
working with pilots accelerating them in
a centrifuge and they would black out as
part of their training
you know to G's 3 G's 4 G's boom out to
go at some point like 10 G's and most of
them have these little dream --let
states that he called them which are
kind of like I saw a tunnel a white
light at the end of the tunnel I felt
myself floating out of the seat and
having these sort of weird experiences
and we know exactly what that is you
know the the blood is being compressed
to the center of the body including the
center of the brain the last thing to go
is your brainstem of course to keep you
alive so the cortex is shutting down
from the outside in that would create
this kind of tunneling effect on the
back of your skull where your visual
cortex is that would create
and that open brain surgeries these are
on epileptic patients where they cut
them open and they poke around to see
where the seizures are starting and and
so they could you know zap those neurons
instead of some big crude attack anyway
so while they're doing that they get
permission from the patient to wake them
up while they're under and the brain is
open and they tap around with electrodes
so this is one way to map what the brain
is doing if you know so what do you
report when I tap here oh I just had a
vision of my tenth birthday or whatever
and it's like okay that's where that
that's stored right there well there's
another spot right on the temporal lobes
just above your ears where you can tap
it and the person says oh I'm floating
out of my body I'm up by the ceiling now
and you tap a little to the left on my
left leg is up my right leg is up and my
left arm is floating my writer and I
miss floating I'm Way up out here now
now I'm coming back down just by you
know with a rheostat just controlling
how much electricity is going into the
neurons in that one particular spot so
we know for sure that the near-death
experiences are in the brain
experiences that the people report are
real they have experience but we know
it's neurologically based now the
counter-argument is yes of course you
have to have your brain to have
experiences but it's a kind of a like a
doors of perception opening into this
other realm hmm that these chemicals
allow you to do it's like was by the way
I've been talking with Graham Hancock
about ayahuasca
he's invited me to come join him and
rythme in Costa Rica to try this I've
never tried this and I'm tempted to go
do this to say okay let's do I'm gonna
write about these things I should
experience it and but there's a debate
amongst people who do this that you know
it is it strictly just in your head and
you're not actually going anywhere or
does it open some door to some other
dimension okay that's kind of the and
and so the the near-death experience
believers counter that well yes it's in
your brain but it still is taking you
somewhere else the problem is is that
how you tell the difference between I
had a personal experience that the only
way you can share it is if you actually
go through it yourself for a scientific
community that studies it well there's
to be some way to test it somehow or
tell the difference between
so is that the limitations of the
scientific method yes yes we're dealing
with consciousness and you're dealing
with memories and dreams and ideas like
you can't measure those either that's
right so I quote two other sources okay
so first of all I discuss the most
famous example is even Alexander's trip
to heaven he wrote a book called proof
of heaven now this is a harvard-trained
neurologist he knows more about the
brain than I do and so he knows all the
research I'm talking to you about and
there's a lot more so but for him it was
so powerful and okay what's it like so
he talks about in his book you know he
was in a coma in in a hospital okay so
he takes this trip and the colors were
unbelievably intense and rich and I felt
just deep personal love for the people I
saw and and oneness with the cosmos and
you know he goes on and on about this so
then I quote from Oliver Sacks his
memoir when he talks about in the 60s
when he was dropping acid and you know
the colors were incredibly intense and I
had this incredible feeling of love and
connecting and I quote from sam Harris's
the opening pages of waking up you know
I took ecstasy and I'm sitting there on
the couch with my buddy and all of a
sudden I feel this intense love for my
friend in other words you know the
narratives are indistinguishable to an
outsider mm so how do you know that
you're actually going to heaven or
you're just having a fantastic trip well
it's entirely possible it's both well so
how do we know don't know that I think
the real problem is people saying that
they know right right saying that I know
that I was in another dimension right no
I mean it's entirely possible that your
consciousness is capable of going
through these chemical doorways that are
created by these molecules and that it
experiences some frequency on the on the
dial like if there's a radio dial maybe
we're at ninety five point five you can
get to 97 if you take you know X amount
of milligrams of dimethyltryptamine and
then you go to this new place you know
this is still physically here you know
Aldous Huxley's book the doors of
perception as which supposedly is where
the doors got their name but that's I
mean somebody told that's that that's a
meme that's not true I don't know anyway
but that's the idea yeah
sounds good so but really what you're
getting at is
a super quart problem of what is truth
know what's so mystical experiences are
by definition personal and you can't
corroborate them through some external
scientific method so I mean science is
based on the fact that we can falsify a
claim we can test it somehow and that
it's not just me pointing to something
and say I think that's true because I
experienced that you know so I wrote a
column in Scientific American methods
called what is truth is I start off with
like well I the truth for me is that
dark chocolates better than milk
chocolate then maybe you say no milk
chocolates better than dark chocolate
and it you know there's no way we're
gonna resolve that but is that true
that's just preference that's just
that's an internal state or I say the
other example I use is you know stairway
to heaven is the greatest rock song of
all time then you go
no no free bird is better than stairway
- okay you can't resolve these things
right so you slide therefrom into things
like these personal experiences we have
so you know so what I think Graham is
hoping if I go to rythme and try
ayahuasca and I say wow I report this
fantastic experience I had presumably
I'll have this and then it'll be well
did I Michael Shermer go to this other
dimension and now I really kind of as a
skeptic need to renounce my pure
materialistic mona stick belief and
admit there's a dualistic that's another
side there's a spirit side or something
and I'm not at all sure I could do that
because how would I get out of my own
head and say I know for sure that I went
to this other place because I wouldn't
know
[Applause]